I'm very excited I'm a lucky girl I saw
the episode of badeley
in New York
it's great to see here tonight for the
season four premiere in the UK for Game
of Thrones now of course we're looking
forward to seeing Davos back on the
small screen what advice would you give
him at rezaian he's in a world of heart
with Stannis isn't he and unappreciative
boss Sansa she's been putting on this
facade of her former self she's been
pretending to be innocent and naive for
the past maybe season and people don't
realize that she's picking up the other
hand the hits from Cersei and Margaery
and she's eventually gonna use them
against me whether they like it or not
my advice to him would be just relax
don't push it you know take your time
try and judge the territory
don't don't don't give too much away
keep a cool head and and stay your
course don't get too hot-headed I would
say to him don't be so trusting and and
left the booze mostly stop taking life
so seriously it's not that bad no he's
been for a lot maybe I wouldn't say that
a bit insensitive the biggest
development for Sam would be to
acknowledge just how brave he already is
I don't think it needs to get any brave
she's definitely growing into herself
she's not this season she kind of
becomes the real sorcerer instead of you
know
so disillusioned by fairytales and
princes she definitely she becomes kind
of this woman who really realizes that
the world is not a fairytale life it's a
fairy tale
it's just got a stick with it I mean as
a character Davos is a you know his his
loyalties is one of his best traits and
the fact that he does say and there is
good insanity
under he he feels a great sense of
responsibility and also believes that
for for Westeros that Stannis is the
best man for the job if you had your
free right in front of you now and you
could say anything to him what would you
say and why you know you definitely put
will out yeah you you would have two
people out cuz Joffrey is a horrible
horrible person it's very difficult to
say your favorite moment because some of
them are truly disgusting but as an
actor I mean it's a complete joy to play
those kind of characters you find
yourself going home in the evening all
full of the joys of spring and bringing
flowers home chocolates and all sorts
because you got rid of the demons during
the day just gets worse and worse I
think there's something really sinister
about the beginning of season 3 when
he's watching the fight and yesterday
Tony Wei has to drink all that wine
there's something so kind of underlying
and sinister and just you know something
is bubbling he just plays it so well it
was Jack in front of me I give him the
big hug him Jack is the most sweet
lovely kind of character he's it
absolutely gorgeous gorgeous go and very
clever guy as well and so I mean it's
it's a joy it must be fabulous to be
what about hated men in the world
sometimes violence is the only answer if
something that you that you care about
so much it is in giving of baby Sam or
John if some feels that they're being
threatened I think that it's a huge
moment of awaking for him where he may
be realized that violence is the only
way of ensuring that they do stay safe
you know people like can use Cersei and
Joffre and you know Tywin they all
better watch their backs
Sansa's coming together big time